aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 moras azules 5
moras azules y también tenemos una 2 3
cerezas 3 cerezas ahora si quiero
descubrir cuántas frutas tengo en total
quiero saber el total de piezas de
frutas que tengo aquí que debería ser
tengo que sumar 5 3 o tengo que restar
restar 5 menos 3 para obtener el total
de piezas de fruta que tengo los ánimos
que pausa en el vídeo ahora y traten de
pensar cuántas piezas de fruta tenemos
en total
quiero saber el total de frutas empiezo
con 5 moras azules y luego tengo 3
piezas más voy a sumar 3 voy a tener un
número mayor de piezas de fruta empiezo
con 5 y sumó 3 cuántas piezas de fruta
tengo en total bueno voy a contar 12
78 piezas de fruta y aquí escribo 8 53
es igual a 8 y ahora cuando el 5 menos 3
que significa 5 menos tres bueno podemos
empezar con cinco piezas de fruta y
déjenme copiar y pegar estas cinco
piezas de fruta las voy a copiar y las
voy a poner aquí abajo
ok empiezo con cinco piezas de fruta y
voy a restar tres restar significa que
voy a quitar las entonces quitó una
quito dos y quito tres y cuántas me
quedan bueno me quedan estas de aquí que
son 25 menos 3 es igual a 2 ok si
alguien dice tengo 5 moras azules y
luego tengo 3 en esas más cuantas piezas
de frutas tengo en total lo que estoy
haciendo es sumar pero si tengo 5 moras
azules y me como 3 cuantas me quedan
sólo 2